dans ces hélicoptères la délégation
ukrainienne arrive en biélorussie c'est
ici près d'eux comme elle dans une
résidence du président biélorusse
alexandre loukachenko qu'elle doit
discuter avec les émissaires russes
objectifs l'arrêt des combats mais dans
une allocution le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky prévient il exige un
cessez le feu et le départ des troupes
russes qu'ils interpellent directement
soldats russes déposez vos armes et
rentrez chez vous et obéissez à vos
supérieurs il ne croyait pas voir son
propagande ont sauvés juste sarthe et
aurait dit
côté russe pas d'exigences clairement
affichée mais les diplomates soulignent
que l'ukraine devra faire des
concessions
dans mon esprit
ce qu'il faut bien souligner c'est qu'à
chaque heure qui passe l'armée
ukrainienne subi davantage de pertes
de notre côté nous sommes résolus à
trouver un accord le plus rapidement
possible
mais cet accord devra profiter à toutes
les parties
l'armée russe à transiter par la
biélorussie pour envahir l'ukraine par
le nord ce qui avait poussé volodymyr
elin ce qui a refusé dans un premier
temps les négociations sur le sol
biélorusse sur le terrain les trois
offensives russes ne se poursuive pas au
même rythme si au sud les soldats russes
occupent désormais la ville de bergues
en ce qu ils n'ont toujours pas pris
kiev selon certains observateurs l'armée
russe ralentirait pour faciliter la
tenue des discussions elle rencontrera
aussi une forte résistance des troupes
du craignait au cinquième jour des
combats la russie subit de lourdes
sanctions économiques tandis que
l'ukraine s'enfonce dans un conflit qui
pousse des milliers de civils à fuir
mais chaque camp aura à coeur de
paraître vainqueur de quoi faire
craindre un échec de ces négociations